uh this one is from dagger yeah okay
this is a nice one actually because
yesterday ever been Furious during the
chess match he's one of the most
positive just see most and I wonder if
his emotions ever got the best of him
as a result of the matches yeah doesn't
have to be his own match that's an
interesting yes
one time I kind of lost emotional no
yeah
it was it was pretty pretty bad it was
probably singularly speaking is maybe
the worst experience I ever had of her
chessboard So what had happened was in
1986 I played as um Olympiad the US
versus USSR and on board one I beaten
Gary Kasparov in the US beat this
incredible Soviet team and in fact we
were going into the last round with the
lead we were in gold medal position over
the Soviets then the next year what the
next Olympiad in 88 Thessaloniki I think
that Gary just had an enormous amount of
pressure on his shoulders and somehow
that carried over in this match and as
we were playing he began to really
press
pieces but really began to hit the clock
very hard and it was getting more and
more annoying slowly slowly yeah
my tolerance was getting really really
really too much
and then he did something that I've
never seen before or since this was
really amazing
he made a move squished it into the
board and hit the clock with a closed
fist yes but he hit the those days we
had these big big clocks and it
depressed the table
and bounced up or all the pieces fell
over no oh really the pieces fell over
but not just on my board the next two is
Boris Coco versus Anatoly karpov their
pieces fell over too
this was too much for me yeah so what
did you do I got I was ready to hit him
off the table and he immediately sets
the danger sorry yes yes sorry sorry he
began putting all the pieces up my time
is ticking yes and I had like four
minutes yes and like I was so
emotionally charged it took like two
minutes for me just to calm down of
course no that's a crazy situation long
story short uh the position was even I
decided to play for a win with less time
instead of making a draw I lost the game
jet streams of profanity
followed me to the hotel it was
tough uh Gary was just I understood
later of course he was under so much
pressure but it was just bad behavior at
that particular moment that just really
threw me
for a loop Boy was I yes upset yes but I
mean these members do you bring them I
haven't been recovered
pick another lifetime uh for me to
recover from that one that was pretty
tough and
unfortunately uh my teammates were also
really angry too in those days we didn't
really make these kinds of complaints to
the appeals committee but a lot of uh my
teammates let's say were of that opinion
that we have to do something yes this
was this was bad behavior yes like you
you could probably complain you could
stop for example the clocks this day and
complain to the Arbiter that my opponent
pushed Concepts
but I was uh yeah that was that was a
word thank you for the
remembering Elaine